kid rock bob richie
who is an adult man who
you know i love i was thinking about
what did i love about kid rock as a
fan as a listener and i just remember
being
i remember being poor and white and
thinking
he just was able to kind of express the
he was this rap like
i mean it was it wasn't country
it was like rap
rock a bit i want to say rockabill i
don't know i don't know enough about
music to know the exact genre and i
think it was kind of a new genre it was
just this
it was something i could fit into you
know
i mean i or something i could was just
like oh here's a guy who
just is it's like a poor white guy who's
saying who's
who's angry and brash
and i could just relate to a lot of that
you know uh because the world i grew up
in the environment
that i sprouted through was a crass it
was crass
and it was but it was passionate and it
was
i don't know anyway so um
live my life in a slow hill and when he
did that slowing with sheryl crow come
on boy
come on and she would sing and you get
kind of erect a little and then he would
sing you'd have to cover it up
you know
god i mean that was just damn
that was a lot but anyway so we went out
to dinner which was really neat
and uh just to be in the presence of
people that are
telling stories you'll never get to hear
and
um and it was just really it was a good
time but anyway afterwards we went
uh we're out here in the central east
and kid rock has an establishment
bob is his name sorry has an
establishment uh
and it's a domicile for liquor and music
and um so we walked over there from the
restaurant we're at
and dude i've walked with
some heroes right some unique humans
i've walked with criminals i walked with
a buddy of mine that killed somebody
and and he said it felt pretty good
honestly uh
but um anyway so we're walking down the
street and you start to and it's so it's
just
drunk people right it's like a french
quarter type of vibe when you're walking
down the street and
and you see people just start to notice
bob
and they start to get
i mean people are losing it you know
some guy tried to spell out bob with a
bob at a bang at a bang boogie
he just tried to he started spelling it
out like a police officer had said all
right i need you to recite this
you know some girl threw her ovary at
him
some girls running for him ran right
into a uh do not park here sign
i see some dude crashed his car he's
like
some fella drank his own blood put a
thing into his side of him started just
sipping on it dude
just i mean people were
losing their minds and he had like
security but it was just
i mean people were just uh some woman
got down and proposed to her husband
every person every like space he walked
past something insane would happen
a window shattered a baby in a stroller
probably four months got out of the
stroller and just started walking walked
off his parents are sitting there kind
of hugging
he's i'm out of here i'm gonna do my own
thing
i'm looking for my real dad elon musk i
mean it was just crazy
fireworks a dove pulled a magician out
of his hat
he had a hat on he pulled a magician out
the magician was wondering if he was
getting his stimulus payment the bird
flew
off but every moment we went pat like
people were getting rock
a caterpillar admitted that he was just
a cat
and it was all just a ruse to meet women
with the long you know
trying to show them that length show
them that bodywork
um so it was just you know it was just a
fat it was just
because look i've i've ridden in cars
and arrived at places
with people with unique uh with pomp and
circumstance
but to ship but to walk
not a mile but walk one one fifteenth of
a mile
not in someone's shoes but near
someone's shoes
um it was just it was i don't know it
was just interesting
you know you just it just doesn't happen
uh every day and certainly not to me
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one